mesdames et messieurs merci monsieur le
maire de nos accueillir aux mureaux est
aujourd'hui à la fois posé des actes et
avoir un échange sur un sujet aussi
important pour notre république
dans votre ville dans votre département
n'est pas un hasard
vous êtes une terre de combat
républicain et vous savez les mener une
ville de solutions comme vous avez
coutume de le dire est un département
terre de contrastes mais qui a toujours
su par l'école la formation le travail
affronter ces défis
l'objectif de notre rendez vous
d'aujourd'hui est double d'abord définir
la réalité de nos problèmes sans tabou
mais sans facilité non plus qu'est-ce
qui aujourd'hui dans notre société met
en danger notre république
notre capacité à vivre ensemble et vous
faire part des décisions prises en
conséquence qu'ils sont le fruit d'un
travail méthodique conduit depuis près
de trois ans et que nous avons ces
dernières semaines finalisé avec le
gouvernement le problème ce n'est pas la
laïcité gelé plusieurs fois rappelé la
laïcité en république française c'est la
liberté de croire ou de ne pas croire la
possibilité d'exercer son culte
à partir du moment où l'ordre public et
assurer la laïcité c'est la neutralité
de l'état et en aucun cas l'effacement
des religions dans la société dans
l'espace public
la laïcité c'est le ciment de la france
unie
si la spiritualité relève du domaine de
chacun la laïcité est notre affaire à
tous et donc les républicains sincères
ne doivent jamais céder à ceux qui au
nom du principe de laïcité tente de
susciter des divisions des
confrontations à partir de multiples
sujets qui bien souvent sont l'essentiel
de nos discussions mais pas l'essentiel
du problème en la matière nous avons des
règles
il nous faut les faire respecter
fermement
et justement partout sans concession de
la même manière
ne nous laissons pas entraîner dans le
piège de la malle gamme vendus par les
polémistes et par les extrême qui
consisterait à stigmatiser tous les
musulmans
ce piège c'est d'ailleurs celui que nous
tendent les ennemis de la république qui
consisterait à faire de chaque citoyen
de confession musulmane un allié
objectif parce qu'il serait la victime
d'un système bien organisé professe-t-il
ce à quoi nous devons nous attaquer
c'est le séparatisme islamistes
c'est un projet conscient théorisé
politico religieux qui se concrétise par
des écarts répétés avec les valeurs de
la république qui se traduit souvent par
la constitution d'une contre société et
dont les manifestations sont la
déscolarisation des enfants le
développement de pratiques sportifs
culturels communautariser qui sont le
prétexte pour l'enseignement de principe
qui ne sont pas conformes aux lois de la
république
c'est l'endoctrinement et par celui ci
la négation de nos principes d'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes la
dignité humaine le problème c'est cette
idéologie qui affirme que ces lois
propres sont supérieures à celles de la
république
et je l'aï souvent dit je ne demande à
aucun nos citoyens de croire ou de ne
pas croire de croire un peu ou
modérément ce n'est pas la sphère de la
république mais je demande à tout
citoyen quelle que soit sa religion ou
pas de respecter absolument toutes les
lois de la république et il y a dans cet
islamisme radical puisque c'est le coeur
du sujet abordons le hainaut mon le une
volonté revendiquée afficher une
organisation méthodique pour contrevenir
aux lois de la république et créer un
ordre parallèle érigé d'autres valeurs
développer une autre organisation de la
société séparatistes dans un premier
temps mais dont le but final est de
prendre le contrôle complet celui ci et
c'est ce qui fait qu'on en vient ainsi
progressivement à rejeter la liberté
d'expression la liberté de conscience le
droit au blasphème que insidieusement
ont conduit à se radicaliser
près de 170 personnes pour ne citer
qu'un exemple sont suivis pour
radicalisation violente ici dans les
yvelines
on vient parfois jusqu'à aller faire le
djihad
nous savons que nous avons 70 jeunes qui
sont partis en syrie dans le département
et qui sont souvent des enfants de la
république
suivant cette dérive allant même jusqu'à
passer à l'acte en tentant de verser le
sang ou parfois jusqu'au pire c'est
aussi cette voie que nous avons dont
nous avons encore vu les manifestations
vendredi dernier à proximité des locaux
de charlie hebdo
à cet égard quand j'évoque tout cela je
n'oublie évidemment ni le moment ni le
lieu où nous parlons le moment celui du
procès des attentats de janvier 2015 et
j'ai une pensée émue et fraternelle pour
les familles
blessé familles de victimes et leurs
proches qui ont vécu l'horreur en
janvier 2015 et je veux ici aussi parce
que je n'oublie pas le lieu rendre
hommage à toutes les victimes du
terrorisme et en particulier au
commandant de police jean baptiste
salvin et à sa compagne jessica
schneider dont le souvenir est encore
vivace aux mureaux mais en disant tout
cela en rappelant chacune de ces étapes
si je puis dire qui n'est pas un chemin
univoque d'une fatalité
je ne veux qu'il n'y ait aucune
confusion ni aucun amalgame aucune de
ces réalités ne doit être écrasés l'une
sur l'autre
mais force est de constater qu'il y à un
islamisme radical qui conduit à nier les
lois de la république qui conduit à
banaliser la violence et qui a conduit
certains de nos citoyens de nos enfants
à choisir le pire ou à considérer que le
pire était devenu naturel et donc à
créer les conditions de dérives
politiques mais aussi de dérive violente
celle du terrorisme islamiste
ce qui est aujourd'hui notre défi c'est
de lutter contre la dérive de certains
au nom de la religion en veillant à ce
que ne soient pas visés ceux qui veulent
croire en l'islam et sont pleinement
citoyens de notre république
le font depuis des années nous sommes
encombré par cette réalité
voulez-vous dire les choses est
considéré que des millions de citoyens
vivent dans la république comme citoyen
pmi entier et croient dans l'islam
on vous dit vous êtes naïf vous les
trouverez
ne regardez pas le problème en face
voulons-nous répondre à ces dérives que
j'évoque y compris dans leurs chambres
les plus radicales on tombe dans le
piège de stigmatiser toute une religion
le chemin c'est celui que je viens de
tracer isoler le problème celui de
l'islamisme radical savoir que chacune
de ces étapes peut mécaniquement
entretenir l'autre et donc ne céder à
aucune facilité aucun cynisme dire les
choses et accepter aussi que nous sommes
face à un défi qui a mis des décennies à
se constituer dans notre pays et que
nous ne le terra seront pas en
mais c'est ensemble que nous devons dans
un réveil républicain nous opposer à
ceux qui veulent nous séparer beaucoup
de choses ont été écrites décrite
analyser très profondément sur ce que
notre pays vit à cet égard j'aurais
l'humilité de ne pas me prétendre un
spécialiste mais en quelques mots pour
partager les choses telles que je les
vois l'islam est une religion qui vit
une crise aujourd'hui partout dans le
monde
nous ne voyons pas que dans notre pays
c'est une crise profonde qui est lié à
des tensions entre des fondamentalismes
des projets justement religieux et
politiques qui on le voit dans toutes
les régions du monde conduisent à un
durcissement très fort y compris dans
des pays où l'islam est la religion
majoritaire regarder notre ami de
tunisie pour ne citer que cet exemple il
ya trente ans la situation était
radicalement différente dans
l'application de cette religion la
manière de la vivre et les tensions que
nous vivons dans notre société sont
présentes dans celle ci qui est sans
doute l'une des plus éduqués développer
la région et donc il y à une crise de
l'islam partout qui est gangréné par ses
formes radicales par ces tentations
radical et par une aspiration à un jihad
réinventer qui est la destruction de
l'autre le projet de califat
territoriales contre lequel nous avons
lutté au levant contre lequel nous
luttons sel mais partout des formes plus
ou moins insidieuse les plus radicales
cette crise nous touche par définition
aussi à cela s'ajoutent les influences
extérieures et une organisation
méthodique de pouvoirs politiques
d'organisations privées qui ont poussé
ses formes les plus radicales et il faut
bien le dire que nous avons laissé faire
chez nous comme à l'étranger wahhabisme
salafisme frères musulmans beaucoup de
ses formes était au début d'ailleurs
pacifique pour certaines elles sont
progressivement dégénéré dans leur
expression
elles se sont elles même radicalisé
elles ont porté des messages de rupture
un projet politique
une radicalité dans la négation par
exemple de l'égalité femmes hommes et
par des financements extérieurs par un
endoctrinement venant de l'extérieur
elles ont atteint notre territoire dans
son intimité
cette réalité nous touche nous frappe
elle a grandi ces dernières années il
faut la nommer à cela s'ajoute le
terreau sur lequel tout ce que je viens
de décrire cette établi nous avons
nous-mêmes construit notre propre
séparatisme c'est celui de nos quartiers
c'est la ghettoïsation que là que notre
république avec initialement les
meilleures intentions du monde mais a
laissé faire c'est à dire que nous avons
une politique
on a parfois appeler ça une politique de
peuplement mais nous avons construit une
concentration de la misère et des
difficultés et nous le savons très bien
nous avons concentré les populations
souvent en fonction de leurs origines de
leurs milieux sociaux nous avons
concentré les difficultés éducatives
économiques dans certains quartiers de
la république
nous avons malgré les efforts des élus
des préfets de la république
je salue l'engagement nous n'avons pas
pu à cause justement de cela
suffisamment recréer de mixité et
surtout nous n'avons pas réussi à aller
aussi vite que ce phénomène en termes de
mobilité
éducative et sociale et donc nous avons
créé des quartiers où la promesse de la
république n'a plus été tenus et donc
des quartiers où l'attraction de ces
messages ou ses formes les plus
radicales qui était source d'espoir qui
a porté et qui apporte
soyons lucides des solutions pour
éduquer les enfants apprendre la langue
d'origine
s'occuper des personnes âgées fournir
des services permettent de faire du
sport au fond ce que la république n'a
plus à porter parce qu'elle était
submergé par ses propres difficultés
parce que parfois elles avaient reculé
en termes de services publics
eh bien ces organisations les porteurs
de cet islam radical s'ils sont
méthodiquement substituer et donc sur
nos recul parfois nous lâche t il ont
construit leur projet méthodiquement là
aussi
c'est pourquoi
les insuffisances de notre politique
d'intégration de nos luttes contre la
discrimination du racisme comme de
l'antisémitisme l'un se nomme l'un
nourrit sans l'autre on aussi
progressivement favoriser se développe
j'ajoute un dernier point pour ce qui
est de notre pays et essayer de décrire
de manière je dirais la plus humble sans
doute imparfaite mais ce que nous avons
vécu ce que nous vivons s'ajoutait tout
cela le fait que nous sommes un pays qui
a un passé colonial et 7,1 fille et qui
a des traumatismes qu'il n'a toujours
pas réglé avec des faits qui sont
fondateurs dans notre psyché collective
dans notre projet dans notre manière de
nous voir la guerre d'algérie en fait
partie et au fond tous eu toute cette
période de notre histoire et revues
comme à rebours parce que nous n'avons
jamais déployé les choses même et donc
nous voyons des enfants de la république
parfois d'ailleurs enfants ou petits
enfants de citoyens aujourd'hui issus de
l'immigration est venu du maghreb de
l'afrique subsaharienne revisiter leur
identité par un discours post coloniale
aux anti coloniale nous voyons des
enfants dans la république qui n'ont
jamais connu la colonisation dans les
parents sont sur notre sol et les grands
parents depuis longtemps mais qui tombe
dans le piège là aussi méthodique de
certains autres qui utilisent ce
discours cette forme de haine de soi que
la république devrait nourrir contre
elle-même mais aussi de tableau que nous
avons nous même entretenu et faisant
miroiter leurs origines avec notre
histoire nourrissent aussi se sépara dit
je distingue chacun de ces éléments
méthodiquement mais ils se mélangent
tous dans la réalité de nos vies ils se
mélangent tous ils se nourrissent les
uns des autres et le projet politique
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que je les
appelais séparatisme islamistes parce
que il s'émancipe parfois même de la
structure religion dans un projet conçu
et bien mélange toutes ces réalités mais
elles sont là et donc il nous faut
affronter avec beaucoup de détermination
et de force les formes inacceptable et
radicales aujourd'hui à court terme il
nous faut reconquérir tous que la
république a laissé faire et qui a
conduit une partie de notre jeunesse où
nos citoyens à être attirés par cet
islam radical et nous faut aussi revenir
sur nos propres traumatismes et nos
propres insuffisances pour en quelque
sorte ouvrir ce livre et je le dis parce
que c'est tout cela qu'il nous faut
tenir ensemble si nous avons un discours
réducteur nous enverrons un message
simple à toute la jeunesse des quartiers
nous ne nous aimons pas vous n'avez pas
de place dans la république filer vers
chez eux
si nous avons un message naïfs nous
laisseront aussi filer toute une partie
de notre république et vive qui nous
dira ils ne savent pas s'attaquer au
problème de mon quotidien
j'envie les conséquences voile école qui
ferme à côté de chez moi les pratiques
l'association les psalmodies heures il
nous faut traiter les deux tout à la
fois en dépliant chacun des points que
je viens d'évoquer
et donc c'est une action qui commence
aujourd'hui et c'est une action tous
ensemble que nous devrons mener et qui
prendra des années et des années
sur ce sujet nous agissons depuis le
premier jour avec beaucoup de force de
détermination sur le terrain nos
fonctionnaires sont à pied d'oeuvre
je ne vais pas ici redire tout ce qui a
été fait depuis trois ans en matière de
lutte contre le terrorisme mais beaucoup
a été fait par nos services de
renseignements par nos forces de
sécurité intérieure par nos magistrats
des lois votées dès le début du
quinquennat une organisation nouvelle
des services de renseignement mieux
coordonner un parquet spécialisé créé
des moyens accordés
trente deux attentats déjoués mais les
choses se sont aussi transformé
accompagnant les mutations que je viens
d'évoquer
nous avions affronté un terrorisme
importées nous avons ce qu'on appelle un
terrorisme endogène dans les formes se
sont hybridés et qui est aux confins
pour certains des dérives qui viennent
de l'islam radical pour d'autres aux
confins de la psychiatrie et de la
radicalisation politico religieuse avec
parfois des individus on le sait très
isolé qui peuvent en quelques heures se
radicaliser et donc il nous faut
continuer avec détermination force et
c'est la mission engagements du ministre
de l'intérieur
à ses côtés de tous les fonctionnaires
auprès de lui c'est aussi la mission du
garde des sceaux pour continuer à
déjouer à avancer à reconquérir
nous avons aussi depuis 2010 est accru
la lutte contre la radicalisation là
aussi avec des actes clairs précis ferme
dès la fin 2010 est des plans de lutte
contre la radicalisation impliquant
l'ensemble des services de l'état ont
été déployés à bas bruit dans 15
quartiers de manière extrêmement
confidentielles pour avoir des méthodes
les plus efficaces avec une coopération
de tous les services de l'état des
magistrats sur le terrain des services
de renseignement 212 débits de boisson
15 lieux de culte
quatre écoles très établissement
associatif et culturel ont été fermés
des centaines de contrôles réalisés des
millions d'euros saisis dans ces
quartiers les résultats obtenus nous ont
conduits à étendre cette méthode à
l'ensemble du territoire
les résultats nous les avons cette
méthode a éprouvé son efficacité nous
l'étendons et nous l'amenons maintenant
partout sur le sol français dans chaque
département des cellules de lutte contre
l'islamisme et le repli communautaire
ont été installés l'hiver dernier elles
ont déjà permis d'interdire des
conférences organisées par des
mouvements islamistes radicaux d'entravé
financièrement une association détourne
en s'arrosant de sa raison d'être pour
promouvoir l'islam politique ailleurs de
fermer une école clandestine des jeunes
filles de 7 ans portait le voile
intégral etc etc
au total depuis le 1er janvier 2020 400
contrôles ont été effectués 93 fermeture
prononcer les actes sont là je les
assume le gouvernement avec moi ils
valent souvent mieux que les mots nous
continuerons sur ce point d'avancé et je
veux souligner combien le travail qui
est conduit par le gouvernement en
matière de lutte contre les stupéfiants
et contre les bandes organisées est un
travail jumeau de celui ci parce que
bien souvent ces réseaux un islam
radical sont financièrement organisée en
lien avec les stupéfiants en lien avec
une économie qui les nourrit et organise
si je puis dire les propres désordre du
quartier où son propre ordre parallèle
tout ça se tient
ce plan coordonné déterminé que nous
continuerons de mener
nous n'avons jamais fait preuve
d'angélisme de naïveté ces actions
n'avaient jamais été mises en oeuvre
avec un tel esprit systématique et une
telle méthode
il nous faut donc aujourd'hui non
seulement les poursuivre mais les
amplifier notre réponse doit être plus
large puissante répondre aux problèmes
concrets observer sur le terrain et la
réponse passe par des mesures d'ordre
public
elle passe aussi par des mesures de
réengagement de la république et au fond
par une stratégie d'ensemble que je veux
ici exposés et qui pour moi à tourner
autour de cinq piliers principaux
c'est une mobilisation de toute la
nation
ce réveil républicain que j'évoque est
ce que nous avons ainsi conçu préparé
mûri c'est le fruit des observations de
terrain de nos fonctionnaires mais aussi
des élus des associations
parce que il nous faudra tous ensemble
la bâtir au coeur de cette stratégie il
y à la mobilisation de beaucoup
d'acteurs la responsabilisation de
certains il y aura aussi un texte de loi
le ministre de l'intérieur et sa
ministre délégué présenteront le 9
décembre prochain en conseil des
ministres un projet de loi qui 115 ans
après l'adoption définitive de la loi de
1905 visera à renforcer la laïcité à
consolider les principes républicains et
l'ensemble des ministres ici présents
ont été fortement contributeur de ce
texte et je les en remercie et
continueront de l'enrichir dans les
jours et semaines qui viennent au fur et
à mesure des concertations et auront à
conduire côtés du ministre et de la
ministre
les débats parlementaires le premier axe
de ce réveil ce patriotisme républicain
sur ce sujet que j'appelle de mes voeux
c'est d'abord un ensemble de mesures
d'ordre public et de neutralité du
service public qui constituent des
réponses immédiates ferme à des
situations constatées connu contraire à
nos principes des élus parfois sous
pression de groupes ou de communautés
ont pu envisager peuvent envisager
d'imposer des menus confessionnels à la
cantine
nous avons sur ce sujet des cas dans des
départements comme la seine-saint-denis
mais aussi en normandie
d'autres élus exclus au projet d'exclure
les hommes les femmes de certains
créneaux d'accès aux piscines ce fut par
exemple le cas dans une commune au moins
d'ici ou des femmes ont revendiqué des
horaires d'accès distinct des hommes à
la piscine une fois la loi votée le
préfet pourra suspendre les actes
municipaux correspondant à ces
situations en constatant cette carence
républicaine et si sa décision n'était
pas assez appliqué se substituer à
l'autorité locale avec l'accord du c'est
à la fois une mesure de protection de ce
qu'il y ait la neutralité des services
publics de ski aussi le maintien de
l'ordre public et c'est ce qui dans
certaines situations peut aussi
permettre de protéger face à de telles
pressions nos élus parce que je ne
sous-estiment pas dans certains la
pression sur le terrain qui peut exister
nous aurons sur beaucoup de sujets au
levant les domaines médical au levant de
l'urbanisme des décisions très concrètes
qui seront portés par ce texte de loi et
qui corresponde là aussi à des
situations observées qui contreviennent
qui à l'ordre public qui à l'égalité
femmes hommes et qu'il est important de
régler avec beaucoup de calme là aussi
de respect de pragmatisme au sein de
nombreux services publiques exercées par
des entreprises en particulier les
transports en commun nous avons aussi vu
ces dernières années se multiplier les
dérives
elle choque et souvent elles sont
constatés avec une forme d'impuissance
parce qu'il ya un contournement de la
loi des contrôleurs qui refuse à des
femmes l'accès au bus en raison de leur
tenue pour être très clair parce
qu'elles n'ont pas une tenue qu'il
considère même comme descente des
demandes de porcs du signe ostentatoire
d'agents certes de délégataire privé
mais d'agente exercent des services
délégués par la commune par le
département par l'état et donc qui
portent ces signes dans le cadre de
leurs missions des phénomènes de
radicalisation poussée qui progresse
nous avons ainsi ces derniers mois
étaient amenés à suivre avec beaucoup
plus d'attention
plus de 80 personnes travaillant dans
les services de roissy charles de gaulle
tous ces sujets montre que là où la
neutralité du service public étaient
claires et établit quant à d dans la
main des fonctionnaires dans les lieux
maîtriser s'étaient installés série de
dérives
lorsque le service public était concédé
ce que ce texte de loi permettra de
faire de manière très concrète c'est que
l'obligation de neutralité sera
applicable aux agents publics dans le
cadre évidemment de leurs actions mais
surtout elle sera étendue aux salariés
des entreprises délégataires ce qui
n'était pas clairement le cas jusqu
alors ce qui nous permettra sur chacune
des situations inacceptables que
j'évoquais d'avoir une réponse claire
ferme d'éviter ces dérives parfois ces
pressions inadmissibles
tous ces faits qui ne sont pas conformes
à nos principes
il fallait s'y attaquer et nous le
faisons avec fermeté et conviction
contrôler et poursuivre sanctionné mais
cela ne suffit pas à l'islamisme radical
brandi comme une fierté nous devons
poser un patriotisme républicain assumé
est allé plus loin
le deuxième axe c'est celui qui concerne
les associations
nos associations sont un pilier de notre
pacte républicain extrêmement importante
le ministre de l'éducation nationale de
la jeunesse et des sports le sait ô
combien et je crois que tous les élus
ici présents et le préfet le savent nos
associations sont des acteurs des relais
et dans notre histoire elles ont forgé
horse du temps si je puis dire stricto
sensu de la république et 2 ou de nos
rites républicains ou du temps de
l'école ou des temps consacrés elle
forge un temps de vie où nos valeurs
sont en partage
et donc il est assez logique que celles
et ceux qui portent ce projet de
séparatisme islamiste est investi le
champ associatif
parce qu'ils n'ont identifié comme la
forme en tout cas l'espace le plus
efficace pour diffuser leurs idées
rendre des services que des associations
laïques ou que d'autres associations
respectant les lois de la république ne
rendait plus parfois que la république
elle-même ne rendais plus est par ce
truchement diffusé de manière subreptice
ou de manière très revendiquer un
message d'islam radical
ce que nous constatons avec vous avec
les médias les préfet avec les
universitaires qui travaillent le sujet
c'est que nombre d'associations
proposant des activités sportives
culturelles artistiques linguistique
autres qui ont pour raison d'être
l'accompagnement des plus précaires ou
l'aide alimentaire des poids en réalité
des stratégies assumer d'endoctrinement
les associations doivent unir la nation
et pas la fracture et nous ne céderons
rien sur ce principe qui est au coeur
même de la liberté qui est associé à la
protection des associations dans notre
pays et au statut si particulier qu'elle
occupe dans la république
les motifs de dissolution des
associations en conseil des ministres
étaient jusque là très limité limité aux
faits de terrorisme de racisme et
d'antisémitisme
ils seront étendus à d'autres motifs
comme les faits d'atteintes à la dignité
de la personne ou de pressions
psychologiques ou physiques
nous devons aller jusqu'au bout nous
allons donc renforcer les contrôles
mettre dans la loi les principes en
vertu desquelles il sera permis de
dissoudre les associations et assumer
que en vertu de nos principes
républicains et sans attendre que ce
soit le pire on puisse dissoudre des
associations dont il est établi qu'elles
portent ces messages qu elles
contreviennent à nos lois et nos
principes avant la dissolution
il ya le financement toute association
sollicitant une subvention auprès de
l'état ou d'une collectivité
territoriale devra signer un contrat de
respect des valeurs de la république et
des exigences minimales de la vie en
société
pour reprendre la formule du conseil
constitutionnel si le contrat est rompu
ces responsables devront rembourser car
il est nécessaire que l'argent public ne
servent pas à financer les séparatistes
cette évidence
beaucoup ont commencé sur cette voie et
d'ailleurs dans votre département je
sais que beaucoup d'élus ont commencé à
faire signer aux associations sportives
ces chartes de laïcité c'est un contrat
renforcé commun que nous proposerons à
l'ensemble des collectivités
territoriales comme modèle que nous
appliquerons et nous avons commencé à le
faire le ministre l'a fait pour
d'ailleurs que les associations relevant
du ministère de la ville et nous sommes
en train de le déployer pour toutes les
associations ministère des sports parce
que c'est une nécessité mais nous
souhaitons que partout état
collectivités sur tout le territoire et
la même nature de contrat et d'exigence
et les mêmes règles en termes de respect
des financements avec là aussi un
contrôle qui sera permis sur cette base
est donc un suivi financier est une
obligation de remboursement comme je
l'évoquais au total sur nos associations
la loi ainsi proposé permettra de
renforcer les éléments de contrôler le
respect de nos valeurs républicaines
mettra des contraintes supplémentaires
en termes de clarté du respect de nos
principes sur les financements et
permettra des dissolutions là aussi
lorsque les infractions sont constatées
sur les principes que j'évoquais c'est
une nécessité
nous faisons en respectant la liberté
d'association avec un travail très fin
qui a été menée par le garde des sceaux
et le ministre de l'intérieur et je les
en remercie
mais je crois aussi que c'est par ce
dispositif que nous pourrons beaucoup
plus efficacement fermer les structures
inacceptable et accroître la pression
sur les associations qui subrepticement
dérive
le troisième pilier de notre stratégie
c'est l'école celui-ci était ô combien
essentielle et vous constaté qu'à mesure
que j'avance dû rentrer si je puis dire
dans l'intimité de notre vie
républicaine l'école c'est le creuset
républicain
c'est ce qui fait qu'on protège nos
enfants de manière complète par rapport
à tout signe religieux à la religion
c'est vraiment le coeur de l'espace de
la laïcité etc ce lieu où nous forgeons
les consciences pour que les enfants
deviennent des citoyens libres
rationnelle pouvant choisir leur vie et
donc l'école et notre trésor collectif
c'est ce qui permet dans notre société
de bâtir ce commun qu'est la république
or là aussi nous avons vu des dérives
nous voyons des contournements et nous
avons un combat mais aujourd'hui plus de
50 mille enfants suivre l'instruction à
domicile un chiffre qui augmente chaque
année
chaque semaine les recteurs et
directrice découvre des cas d'enfants
totalement ce système chaque mois des
préfets ferme des écoles entre
guillemets car elles ne sont pas
déclarés même comme tel il légal souvent
administrés par des extrémistes
religieux partout sur notre territoire
le phénomène que nous voyons et simple
des parents d'élèves qui viennent voir
directeur ou la directrice d'école et
qui disent le cours de musique c'est
terminé
sinon il ne reviendra plus la piscine
avec les autres c'est terminé sinon il
ne reviendra plus et ensuite des
certificats pour allergie au chlore qui
sont 2 mai puis des absences répétées et
enfin la déscolarisation
nous allons l'inscrire au cned ce sera
très bien fait c'est plus simple pour
nous ces enfants ne vont pas au cned
parfois ils ne reçoivent aucune
éducation
mais ils vont dans des structures qui ne
sont nullement déclaré la semaine
dernière nous en avons encore identifié
une en seine saint denis des structures
très simple des murs presque pas de
fenêtre des enfants qui arrivent à 8
heures chaque jour qui repartent à 15h
des femmes en niqab qui les accueillent
et lorsqu'on les interroge les prières
certains cours voilà le renseignement
c'est une réalité
nous devons à regarder la nommer en saas
et sur ce sujet face à toutes ces
dérives qui exclut des milliers
d'enfants de l'éducation à la
citoyenneté de l'accès à la culture un
autre histoire à nos valeurs à
l'expérience de l'altérité qui est le
coeur de l'école républicaine
j'ai pris une décision sans doute ai je
la mesure et nous en avons beaucoup
débattu avec les ministres sans doute
l'une des plus radicales
depuis les lois de 1882 et celles
assurant la mixité scolaire entre
garçons et filles en 1969 dès la rentrée
2021 l'instruction à l'école sera rendue
obligatoire pour tous dès 3 ans
l'instruction à domicile sera
strictement limitée notamment aux
impératifs de santé
nous changeons donc de paradigme
mais c'est une nécessité notre école
ensuite ne peut en aucun cas faire
l'objet d' ingérence étrangère
nous l'avions constaté c'est le fameux
système des locaux d enseignement de
langue et culture d'origine qui
conduisait à avoir sur notre sol dans un
cadre contractuel avec les pays
d'origine des enseignants qu'ils
maîtrisaient parfois pas le français qui
prodiguer un enseignement dans le cadre
de ses locaux je rappelle qui faisait
l'objet de contrats avec l'algérie le
maroc et la turquie d enseignement qui
eux mêmes n'étaient pas conformes aux
lois de la république aux principes
fondamentaux de nos programmes comme je
l'avais annoncé à l'hiver dernier à
mulhouse
un travail a été conduit par le ministre
de l'éducation nationale et le ministre
de l'europe et des affaires étrangères
pour précisément mettre un terme à ce
système et faire en sorte que nous
n'ayons aucun système celui des oeillets
le où nous pouvons avoir un enseignement
en langue arabe une contractualisation
avec ces états mais où nous avons un
contrôle sur les enseignants sur le
respect de nos valeurs et sur les
capacités linguistiques en langue
française de ces derniers c'est à dire
un vrai contrôle de l'éducation
nationale sur la qualité des enseignants
et de l'enseignement
c'est aujourd'hui une réalité
nous sommes en train de parachever les
derniers termes de la négociation
mais au terme de négociations serrées
avec les trois pays que j'évoquais nous
mettons donc bien fin aux locaux ça
n'est pas simplement un projet qui
avaient parfois pu être par le passé
agité discuter c'est une réalité
ensuite parce que l'école doit d'abord
inculquer les valeurs de la république
et non celle d'une religion former des
citoyens non des fidèles les écoles hors
contrats qui sont davantage contrôlés
grâce à la grande avancée que constitue
la loi dite gatel feront l'objet d'un
encadrement encore renforcée je le dis
ici très clairement la liberté
d'enseignement est importante dans notre
république et ne s'agit en aucun cas de
la remettre en cause de réveiller des
patients que notre pays a pu connaître
et qui serait contre-productive
je pense que là aussi il ne faut avoir
aucun amalgame la liberté d'enseignement
nous savons vivre avec nous nous sommes
organisés et les choses avancent bien
mais sur le parcours des personnels le
contenu pédagogique des enseignements
l'origine des financements
il est légitime que l'état en force
les contrôles nous avons tous été
confrontés ces derniers mois à des cas
de lycées et de collèges qui parfois été
financée par l'état par les régions et
sur lesquels nous n'avions pas une
visibilité complète parce que la loi ne
le permettait pas on se réveille quand
le scandale arrive
ce qui est la pire des choses et donc ce
qui a été décidé
c'est de doter le ministère justement
des voies et moyens de contrôler chacun
de ces sujets de pouvoir procéder à des
fermetures administratives quand elle
s'impose et il faut les assumer tout en
respectant la liberté d'enseignement et
sans créer de passion inutile
la république s'est construite autour de
l'école qui forme plus que des individus
qui élèvent des citoyens qui façonne des
esprits libres
c'est pourquoi j'en suis convaincu la
république résistera par l'école à ceux
qui veulent la combattre ou la diviser
et que c'est par l'école que nous
permettront à tous nos enfants d'accéder
au savoir à la culture à la civilité
républicaine et donc à devenir tellement
citoyens et citoyennes
ce projet vous le constatez est
extrêmement ambitieux il a fait l'objet
d'un très grand travail et je vous en
remercie vraiment les ministres mais il
est pour moi un pilier essentiel de sa
stratégie positif mais déterminé le
quatrième axe de la stratégie que nous
entendons conduire de ce réveil
républicain
il consiste à bâtir enfin un islam en
france qui puisse être un islam des
lumières
je suis toujours prudent sur ces
formules on en a eu beaucoup
on a pu parler d'un islam de france je
ne veux pas ici rentrer dans des débats
sémantiques parce que j'ai constaté que
quand je dis introduisait je nourrissais
ensuite énormément de commentaires
donc je ne pense pas qu'il faille une
forme d'islam gallican non mais il nous
faut aider cette religion dans notre
pays à se structurer pour être un
partenaire de la république pour ce qui
est des affaires que nous avons en
partage et c'est normal
les autres religions se sont ainsi
structuré d'abord parce que c'est leur
histoire parfois alors je dirais leur
structure même et nous avons appris à
vivre ensemble
mais là aussi nous nous devons les
finales la lucidité
lorsque la loi de 1905 a été votée
l'islam n'était pas une religion si
présent dans notre pays et elle s'est
beaucoup développée ces dernières années
aussi à travers les vagues migratoires
qui sont plutôt celles du 20e siècle et
donc nous sommes face à une réalité dont
l'organisation ne correspond pas à nos
propres méthodes à nos propres
truchement nos interlocuteurs
aujourd'hui n'assume pas une vraie
responsabilité cultuel et donc il est
très difficile pour le ministre en
charge des cultes des préfets des maires
de savoir à qui il parle
lorsqu'ils veulent pouvoir évoquer les
sujets qui relèvent du culte et ont un
impact sur notre vie en société et
parfois sur l'ordre public parce que le
culte n'y est pas ainsi organiser ça
fait trois ans qu'on travaille sur ce
sujet d'arrache-pied j'ai discuté avec à
peu près tous les spécialistes acteurs
les différentes équipes de direction du
cfcm j'ai pu un moment réfléchir à une
voix celle d'une approche concordataire
et je pense qu'elle était inadapté
autant que nous vivons elle aurait créé
des ruptures avec les autres religions
son cadre juridique aurait été très
fragile et je pense qu'elle aurait sans
doute d'ailleurs suscité des réflexions
contre-productive vous allez vous
occupez vous état d'organiser l'islam
c'est donc vous qui allez financer telle
et telle chose avec l'argent du
contribuable
je vous laisse imaginer ce dans quoi
nous serions rentrés vu la passion des
débats auraient rationnel que nous avons
parfois c'est pourquoi nous avons engagé
un travail de structuration et aussi de
responsabilité partagée il y a
maintenant un peu plus de deux ans le
ministère de l'intérieur a demandé à
chaque préfet dans les départements
d'identifier les interlocuteurs de 10,1
ce qui aujourd'hui n'était pas
véritablement fait vous le savez ce sont
plutôt les crcm qui existe ce travail a
été fait a permis d'identifier dans
chaque département ou dans certains
territoires de manière
interdépartemental les interlocuteurs
donc de structurer un dialogue et nous
avons mené un vrai travail une vraie
réflexion avec le conseil français du
culte musulman et c'est ce chemin que
nous allons ouvrir ensemble c'est à dire
essayer ensemble de bâtir une
organisation qui va nous permettre je
l'espère je le crois de construire un
islam des lumières dans notre pays c'est
à dire un islam qui puisse être en paix
avec la république en respectant toutes
les règles de séparation et en
permettant d'apaiser toutes les voix ce
n'est pas le travail de l'état de
structure et l'islam mais nous devons
nous permettre accompagner cette
émergence et c'est ce que ce dialogue
toute cette préparation nous a permis de
faire d'abord
et c'est le premier point en la matière
en libérant l'islam en france des
influences étrangères
sur ce sujet nous allons faire de deux
manières
parce qu'il ya deux types d' influence
il ya une influence qui est visible qui
est assumée il ya une influence qui est
parfois plus profondes et dangereuse
mais qui est moins visible est moins
assumé la première influence qu on a
décidé de réduire en concertation avec
les pays fait l'organisation même de
l'islam consulaire vous le savez nous
sommes un pays où nous organisions la
formation des imams dans des pays
étrangers mais aussi celle de psalmodie
heures que nous faisions venir de
manière régulière
c'est la turquie le maroc et l'algérie
qui fournissait ses imams et cepsa la
mode hier nous avons décidé de mettre
fin à ce système de manière totalement
apaisé avec les pays d'origine et en
transition c'est-à-dire sur quatre ans
en moyenne ce qu'il faut que les choses
se fassent progressivement parce que je
vais revenir nous allons nous-mêmes
former nos imams et notre salle molière
les musulmans en france et donc nous
devons détacher ce lien qui est celui
qu'on nomme de l'islam consulaire parce
qu'il nourrit des rivalités des
dysfonctionnements mais surtout il
continue de faire porter ce surmoi
postcoloniale que j'ai évoquées par
ailleurs avec énormément d'ambiguïté il
ne permet pas à la structuration de
cette religion dans notre pays d'avancer
comme il faut et je le dis de manière
vraiment très apaisé et en accord à la
fois avec le cfcm et les trois pays que
j'évoquais et donc nous mettons fin à ce
lien à cette influence étrangère l'autre
influences plus pernicieuse plus grave
c'est celle du financement jusqu'à
présent
nous avions une ambiguïté beaucoup de
structures passer par la loi de 1901
pour financer des activités cultuelles
et avec beaucoup de d'opacité des
structures convoi y arriver on en a vu
arriver tellement sur nos territoires
dont nous découvrions qu'elle avait été
financée par telle fondation parfois tel
état étranger tel intérêt sans beaucoup
de transparence les mosquées seront
ainsi inciter à sortir de la forme
associative pour basculer vers le régime
prévu par la loi de 1905 à la fois plus
avantageuse fiscalement et davantage
contrôlés sur les plans des financements
venant de l'étranger
mais au-delà de cela tous ceux qui
continueraient à choisir la voie de 1901
virer un contrôle renforcé drastiquement
en termes d'origine de financement du
contrôle de cette origine et de
transparence sur les fous qu'est ce que
nous allons faire pour parler en termes
simples pour ceux qui connaissent ces
questions nous allons répliquer pour
toutes les associations cultuelles qui
se sont inscrits dans le cadre de la loi
de 1901 les contraintes qui existait
dans le cadre de la loi de 1905 sans les
avantages fiscaux de la loi de 1905
normalement c'est une incitation plutôt
aller vers 1905
mais surtout c'est la fin d'un système
d'opacité il ne s'agit pas d'interdire
les financements venant de l'étranger
il s'agit simplement de les encadrer de
les rendre transparents de les maîtriser
c'est un élément essentiel là aussi pour
libérer l'islam en france des influences
étrangères qui sont rarement pour le
meilleur
et comme nous l'avons constaté plus
souvent pour le pire
et il s'agit véritablement de revenir à
l'esprit et à la lettre de la loi de
1905 au fond que ces contournements et
des décennies de laisser-aller ont
édulcoré
dans la pratique ce que nous allons de
fait faire pour tous les lieux de culte
s'est donc renforcé les contrôles en
termes de financement et aussi sur les
associations qui les portes renforcées
comme je le disais tout à l'heure dans
le deuxième axe notre contrôle sur la
nature de ce qui est dit les actions qui
sont menées et le respect des valeurs de
la république
chez toutes celles et ceux qui les
portent et les font ensuite la volonté
de protéger les responsables des
mosquées des putschs des prises de
contrôle hostile par des extrémistes est
un élément très important de cette
structuration aujourd'hui sur nos
territoires ce que nous voyons et je
sais que les élus ici près
constatée est parfois vécu cette offrons
les prises de contrôle hostile qui
existent au niveau des mosquées pour
aller justement soudainement changé les
dirigeants de l'association cultuelle en
quelques jours et on se réveille en
quelques jours on voit des islamistes
radicaux profiter des faiblesses dans
les statuts pour prendre le contrôle de
l'association de tous ses financements
et mener la pire des politiques
cela n'arrivera plus ce que nous allons
très clairement installé c'est un
dispositif anti putsch très robuste dans
la loi qui permettra d'éviter que ses
protagonistes qui sont les plus subtils
les plus sophistiqués n'utilise les
faiblesses de nos propres règles pour
venir prendre le contrôle des
associations cultuelles et des mosquées
pour aller prédit qu est le pire
organiser le pire souvent mené
d'ailleurs dans le cadre de
l'association cultuelle des activités
qui ne sont pas du tout qui commence à
devenir politique etc
enfin l'ambition de former et promouvoir
en france une génération d'imams mais
aussi d'intellectuels qui défendent un
islam pleinement compatible avec les
valeurs de la république est une
nécessité
l'islam est une religion qui existent en
france
je sais que beaucoup ne veulent pas le
voir et pense que ce serait une manière
efficace de lutter contre l'islam
radical
je pense que c'est une stupidité d'abord
parce que ni elle réelle n'est jamais
une bonne voie et ensuite parce que
comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure
je pense que c'est le plus grand cadeau
qu'on pourrait faire à ceux qui veulent
basculer la république mais il nous faut
comme je le disais aller au bout de
cette structuration et donc ce dont nous
sommes convenus avec le conseil français
du culte musulman c'est que d'ici à six
mois au plus tard celui-ci allait
finaliser un travail largement commencé
depuis plusieurs mois est indispensable
un travail qui consiste
premièrement à labelliser des formation
d'imams dans notre pays deuxièmement à
assumer une responsabilité cultuelle qui
sera celle de la certification des imams
troisièmement d'écrire une charte dont
le non-respect entraînera révocation des
imams la structuration du pèlerinage du
hajj apportera des financements
nécessaires nous avons conduit un très
gros travail avec l'arabie saoudite pour
réglementer celui ci et là aussi un
travail a été mené par le cfcm par la
mif pour justement bâtir une solution
qui permettra d'avoir un si les
financements et de structurer ses
formations
ce que je vous décris là ce n'est pas
l'état qu'il fera en vertu même du
principe de séparation ce sera au
conseil français du culte musulman mais
je lui fais confiance et c'est une
responsabilité immense que nous est
compté mais en même temps je leur ai dit
avec le ministre il ya deux jours c'est
une pression immense que nous allons
exercer sur eux parce que nous n'avons
pas le droit d'échouer et je pense que
c'est aujourd'hui ce dont nous avons
besoin
s'agissant de la dimension
intellectuelle trop fan l'état doit lui
aussi s'engager s'engager et soutenir
ceux qui veulent dans notre pays doit
nous permettre de faire émerger une
meilleure compréhension de l'islam est
aussi une meilleure formation
intellectuelle académique qui des
religieux mais tous nos concitoyens qui
s'intéressent à cette religion à cette
civilisation pour mieux nous connaître
aussi des uns des autres
parce que c'est un enjeu pour nous mêmes
à cette fin nous soutiendrons hauteur de
10 millions d'euros les initiatives qui
seront prises par la fondation pour
l'islam de france en matière de culture
d'histoire et de sciences je pense en
particulier au développement d'études
islamiques de haut niveau à l'université
j'ai dcid aussi que nous allons créer un
institut scientifique d'islamologie et
au bénéfice de la loi sur l'enseignement
supérieur et la recherche
nous créerons des postes supplémentaires
dans l'enseignement supérieur pour là
aussi continuer le travail parfois le
reprendre matière de recherche sur la
civilisation musulmane mais aussi sur le
maghreb le bassin méditerranéen
l'afrique beaucoup de ces sujets où la
france excellé sur le plan académique
ont été affaiblis et nous les avons
abandonné et ce faisant nous avons
laissé le débat intellectuel à d'autres
à ceux qui sont hors de la république en
l'idéologie sens mais parfois à d'autres
traditions universitaires je pense à la
tradition anglo saxonne qui a une autre
histoire et qui n'est pas la nôtre
et quand je vois aujourd'hui certaines
théories en sciences sociales totalement
importé des états de l'amérique avec
leurs problèmes que je respecte et qui
existent mais ils viennent s'ajouter aux
nôtres dit que nous sommes
déraisonnables à faire ce choix et donc
nous devons ré investir nous très
clairement le champ des sciences
sociales de l'histoire de la
connaissance des civilisations
massivement en créant des postes en
développement le dialogue et la
controverse académiques et scientifiques
pour ne pas laisser la connaissance la
compréhension de l'islam comme religion
de la civilisation qu'elle porte de sa
contribution aussi à notre pays et notre
continent à des débats idéologiques et
exclusivement politique
cette tâche nous la mènerons là aussi
avec beaucoup de méthode et de volonté
je veux que la france devienne ce pays
on puisse enseigner la pensée d'averroès
des benjelloun que nous puissions être
un pays d'excellence dans l'étude des
civilisations musulmanes
nous le devons à nous mêmes et nous le
devons
pour cette lutte que j'évoquais parce
qu'il n'y aura pas de réussite du projet
que j'évoque depuis tout à l'heure si
nous ne nous connaissons pas mieux si
nous ne comprenons pas mieux les
civilisations qui de fait cohabitent sur
notre sol compte tenu de ce qu'est
aujourd'hui le peuple français
il nous faut aussi et le ministre de
l'éducation nationale plusieurs reprises
s'est engagé sur ce point enseigner
davantage la langue arabe à l'école ou
dans un périscolaire que nous maîtrisons
car notre jeunesse est aussi riche de
cette culture plurielle et il faut sur
ce sujet sortir de l'hypocrisie dans
laquelle nous sommes
quand nous nous renseignons pas à
l'école ou dans un périscolaire qui est
compatible avec les lois de la
république
nous acceptons qui est plus de soixante
mille jeunes aujourd'hui qui vont la
prendre dans des associations qui leur
propose pour le pire est qu'ils sont
manipulés par ce que j'évoquais et donc
l'arabe mais aussi beaucoup d'autres
langues qui sont la richesse même de nos
enfants de leurs oeufs de leur famille
nous devons savoir dans notre république
à la fois les reconnaître mais les
exaltés les faire vivre dans le cadre
républicain de manière
extraordinairement décomplexée
simplement de manière encore une fois
conforme à nos principes mais
reconnaissant notre richesse
sortons de l'hypocrisie donc ne
délivrons pas cet enseignement et d'ici
à deux ans notre volonté comme nice
c'est d'avoir une vraie politique de
connaissance des langues et des
civilisations aussi à l'école avec des
enseignants et avec des locuteurs qui
sont certifiés au plan linguistique et
dont nous savons qu'ils respectent les
valeurs de la république
enfin et c'est le cinquième axe sur
lequel je voulais insister
s'il faut faire craindre la république
en appliquant ces règles sans faiblesse
et redonner force à la loi s'il faut
reconquérir sur des axes essentiels que
j'ai évoquées il faut aussi la la faire
aimer à nouveau en démontrant qu'elle
peut permettre à chacun de construire sa
vie nous avons en font un devoir
d'espoir et je le dis très simplement
dans le débat qui est le nôtre parce que
hocine une forme d'insécurité qui s'est
installée certains ont qualifié d'
insécurité culturel je crois juste titre
parce que notre société est perclus de
fractures de non dits que nous avons
laissé s'installer
on voudrait croire qu'on peut régler
tous les problèmes par décret par des
lois notre république a réussi quelque
chose d'extraordinaire à la fin du 19e
siècle et au début du 20e siècle
elle a réussi parce qu'elle a conquis
elle a installé un an de républicains
elle a réussi par l'école elle a réussi
par ses services publics par la justice
mais elle a réussi parce qu'elle a fait
aimer la république parce que pour des
tas d'enfants la république à donner un
avenir
et partout la république ne donne plus
d'avenir
n'attendez pas que ses enfants même
malheureusement
et ça ne se décrète pas l'amour ça ne
légifère pas ça se démontre
et donc le travail que nous avons
commencé avec beaucoup de vigueur je
veux ici lui rendre hommage c'est celui
que nous devons intensifier ses implique
en effet de refaire entrer la république
dans le concret des vies et là on a
besoin de le faire avec tous les
fonctionnaires avec tous les élus avec
détermination et je sais que vous êtes
ses combattants et ce qui est très dur
c'est comme beaucoup parfois de terrain
était perdu tout ce qui ce fait ces
dernières années qu'on fait tous
ensemble ça ne se voit pas forcément
assez c'est un caractère ingrat mais je
veux ici le redire avec force le
dédoublement des classes pour trois cent
mille élèves c'est de la république au
concret pour des enfants qui vont
pouvoir apprendre à lire écrire compter
être éduqués dans des territoires les
plus difficiles c'est une réalité les
réformes de l'orientation de
l'accompagnement tout ce qu'on a fait
sur le temps extrascolaire devoirs faits
ses quartiers d'été
cet été avec ce qu'on a appelé les des
apprenants et culturels et sportifs
c'est une reconquête essentiel c'est du
concret pour ces enfants qu'on n'a pas
laissé dans la main d'associations qui
veulent la fin d'article ce travail est
essentiel et nous poursuivrons la
l'ouverture de 80 cité éducative
la labellisation de 530 maisons 30
services dans le secteur culturel
l'extension des horaires d'ouverture des
bibliothèques pour plus de 600 communes
la création comme ici aux mureaux de
près de 100 micro folie c'est une série
d'initiatives de bataille de terrain si
je puis dire qu'on a tous mener ensemble
ces dernières années pour aller
reconquérir et dire la république doit
revenir mais c'est vrai dans toutes les
composantes
lorsqu'on a décidé 10 milliards
supplémentaires pour l'anru à l'airé
compte reconquérir et ouvrir de quartier
redonner des financements aux
associations de terrain décidé comme on
l'a fait cette année de redonner des
crédits à la justice pour permettre la
justice de proximité dans ces maisons
france services mais aussi en redonnant
des moyens très concret pour que la
réponse
de notre justice correspond aussi aux
moyens qu'on met du côté de notre
sécurité
cette la république qui revient et qui
reprend un sens ce qu'on a fait avec les
quartiers de reconquête républicaine
avec la police de sécurité du quotidien
que ministre est en train de déployer là
aussi pour redonner des moyens ce qu'on
fait lorsqu'on se bat contre les
inégalités femmes hommes sur le terrain
en redonnant des moyens aux associations
mais en permettant là aussi à la
république de revenir avec des moyens
des structures
c'est la politique et donc tout cela
s'est déployée depuis trois ans avec
force détermination avec beaucoup de
propositions qui ont été portées par les
ministres qui ont aussi porté par jean
louis borloo dont je veux saluer le
travail l'implication et les idées et
quand je regarde le rapport qui nous
avait été remis plus de trois quarts ont
été mises en oeuvre
on peut s'en féliciter
et je pense que toutes ses énergies nous
en avons besoin et donc ce qu'il nous
faut faire aujourd'hui c'est d'aller
plus loin
nous le ferons avec le dédoublement des
classes actuellement étendue aux élèves
de grande section 40 cité éducative
supplémentaires qui seront créés 300
maisons france services supplémentaires
qui ouvriront dans les prochaines
semaines un investissement
supplémentaire dans la rue sur la
sécurité et sur la justice des
investissements supplémentaires de
concret avec sur le terrain des
magistrats des greffiers des juges
parfois aussi des volontaires qui
viendront aider dans des tâches de
proximité comme vous l'avez développer
monsieur le maire avec aussi des
policiers des gendarmes sur le terrain
et des moyens supplémentaires
notre horizon est simple c'est assurer
une présence républicaine au bas de
chaque tour au bas de chaque immeuble
là où nous avions reculé il faut revenir
là où la réponse de la république
n'était plus intelligible parce qu'on
mettait des mois et des mois à répondre
aux délits on doit redonner du sens
collectivement en permettant à notre
justice de retrouver les moyens de
répondre vite de manière adaptée comme
elle le fait pour que tous retrouvent un
sens pour la victime
comme pour le fauteur de trouble comme
pour nos forces de sécurité nous aimons
la république
au fond tous quand elle tient ses
promesses d'émancipation
tout ce que je viens d'évoquer c'est ce
qui garantit cette promesse
d'émancipation la république c'est à la
fois un ordre et une promesse est donc
ce qu'il nous faut faire avec beaucoup
de force
c'est allé plus loin sur cette voie j'ai
commencé à égréner des pistes pour
l'égalité des chances
nous les poursuivrons en cette matière
dans la lutte contre les discriminations
en matière d'emploi et de logement avec
de nouveaux testing qui ont été décidées
dans la systématisation des quartiers
d'été que j'évoquais que nous allons
pérenniser et pour faire en sorte que
chacun quelle que soit sa couleur de
peau son origine sa religion puisse
trouver sa place ni le racisme et
l'antisémitisme ne sont compatibles avec
la république
c'est pourquoi il nous faut aussi dans
le cadre même de sa stratégie avoir
l'ambition d'aller beaucoup plus loin
que ce que nous avons commencé à faire
je présenterai au cours de l'automne de
nouvelles décisions en la matière et
elles seront déclinés là aussi dans
chaque département par les préfets en
associant tous les élus mais avec des
choses profondes et simple en matière de
logement nous devons changer enfin
radicalement nos textes nous ne pouvons
pas continuer d'ajouter la pauvreté à la
pauvreté tant que nous n'arrêterons pas
cela nous continuerons les difficultés
éducatif de formation et les problèmes
que j'ai évoqué ce texte doit porter une
réforme profonde de notre organisation
en matière de logement en particulier de
logement social de la même manière nous
devons porter assumer la part de la
relance qui ira à ces quartiers de la
république
il doit y avoir une part de ce plan de
relance qui permet l'émancipation
culturelle économique écologique de nos
quartiers arrêtons de traiter une partie
de notre jeunesse de nos citoyens comme
des consommables ou au fond des simples
récipiendaires de politiques publiques
ils veulent faire ils veulent
l'excellence ils veulent qu'on leur
laisse la chance de réussir et donc dans
ce plan france relance il relance il
doit y avoir et il y aura j'aurai
l'occasion de les présenter dans les
prochaines semaines
là aussi des changements profonds pour
permettre à nos quartiers un quartier dé
plus en difficulté de mener des projets
éducatifs culturels entrepreneurs
entrepreneuriaux qui sont souhaités et
de réussir la transition à la fois
numériques et environnemental là aussi
ces transitions peuvent être conduites
là aussi nous devons aider à réussir
mesdames et messieurs vous l'aurez
compris à traverser cinq grands axes que
j'ai voulu évoquer ce matin c'est toute
une stratégie de mobilisation de la
nation pour un réveil républicain
alors j'ai conscience que j'ai peut-être
déçu ceux qui attendaient des
caricatures dans un sens ou dans l'autre
je l'assumé et je continuerai de
l'assumer ce réveil républicain
il ne peut pas être le fait de quelques
uns on n'administre pas des consciences
on gouverne un pays on engage des
citoyens et donc se réveille c'est celui
des responsables politiques que nous
sommes des préfets des policiers des
gendarmes des professeurs des
fonctionnaires des élus des associations
des magistrats de toutes celles et ceux
qui au quotidien ont taffé revit cette
promesse ne m'ont pas attendu pour faire
les constats que j'évoquais mais nous
voulons aujourd'hui leur donner les
moyens de faire et un cadre clarifier et
aussi des moyens en conséquence pour
pouvoir agir se réveille c'est celui de
tous les citoyens
c'est celui d'une france unie autour de
ses valeurs
plus nos ennemis chercherons à nous
opposer plus nous serons rassemblés plus
ils chercheront à nous détruire plus
nous feront bloc plus ils chercheront à
faire vaciller une valeur plus nous
serons intransigeants intransigeant
parce que c'est notre histoire dont il
s'agit mais intransigeant parce que à
cette intransigeance correspond la
bienveillance républicaine que j'ai vu
et je vous le dis avec beaucoup de
conviction il ya au fond derrière cette
question existentielle pour notre nation
à réapprendre les raisons que nous avons
de vivre ensemble chaque jour chaque
jour les uns et les autres veulent
mettre en avant les bonnes raisons nous
diviser nous ne sommes pas une société
d'individus
nous sommes une nation de citoyens cela
change tout on apprend à être citoyen on
le devient ce sont des droits et des
devoirs mais je ne cèderai rien à ceux
qui veulent nous diviser
dans un sens ou dans l'autre parce que
je crois que notre plus beau trésor
c'est ce bloc que nous formons il éteint
et plurielle ne l'oublions jamais c'est
ça la force de notre république
pluriel ça ne veut pas dire que nous
serions un agglomérat de communauté
c'est que nous sommes une communauté
nationale
mais cette communauté nationale à 66
millions d'histoires est quelque chose
qui est à chaque fois plus grand que
chaque individu
ce qui fait qu'un individu devient
citoyen son adhésion à l'universel
républicain c'est cela qu'il nous faut
défendre le gouvernement prendra ses
responsabilités en finance en finissant
le travail sur ce texte de loi
je sais que l'ensemble de celles et ceux
qui servent l'état le feront je sais que
nos élus seront au rendez vous et je
sais que tous nos citoyens prendront
cette part vive la république et vive la
france
je vais maintenant répondre à vos
questions
seignosse on avait cru comprendre que le
texte porterait sur les laits
séparatisme au pluriel à l'aune de ce
que vous venez de dire on voit bien que
c'est le séparatisme islamistes vous
l'avez dit qui est au coeur du sujet
doit-on conclure que le projet de loi
contre les séparatistes mais finalement
un projet de loi contre l'islamisme
radical
et pourquoi alors ne pas plus clairement
nommer les choses je sais pas depuis
combien de temps je m'exprime mais j'ai
pas le sentiment d'être ambiguë la très
sincèrement vous seriez malhonnête à
dire que j'ai pas nommer les choses très
clairement qu'on peut décider de se
faire collectivement dénommés au cerveau
et d'avoir de longs débats sur des
choses inutiles mais je crois que j'ai
dit le problème
après il y à d'autres formes de
séparatisme au nom de religion dérives
sectaires
mais soyons clair ce sont des femmes qui
sont plus minoritaire mais on les
abordera avec ce texte parce que au nom
d'autres religions certains prat ont des
pratiques qui ne sont pas conformes par
exemple à l'égalité femmes-hommes
on le sait bien il ya des pratiques
aujourd'hui secteurs qui ne sont pas
conformes à nos principes et la dignité
humaine donc ils seront abordés dans le
texte tout à fait donc ça n'est pas
exclusif mais ils sont plus marginaux et
le coeur du sujet j'ai pas le loisir de
vous regarder toute la journée mais
généralement quand je croise ou vos
chaînes de télévision journaux vous êtes
assez concentré quand même sur un sujet
sentiments il faut plutôt l'aborder de
manière directe sans faux semblant mais
100 simplifications donc je vous
remercie de l'avoir d'avoir dit le terme
auxquelles je suis attaché en effet
d'islamisme radical qui suit la gelée
suffisamment longuement définit le texte
ce sera un texte pour pour les valeurs
de la république et la république en
actes on a plutôt tendance à faire des
choses pour et c'est difficile de
réengager toute une nation
si on a un projet contre donc on est
parti d'une situation et quelques mois
on disait faut lutter contre les
communautarismes
j'ai essayé en expliquant les choses par
un glissement sémantique de passer du
communautarisme séparatisme et là
j'espère avoir réussi la fin du parcours
qui est de nommer vraiment le problème
la bataille de d'éviter les amalgames et
de dire notre projet c'est un projet
pour il faut on défend nos libertés et
en défend ce projet positif
si évidemment on est intraitable sur
ceux qui ont plutôt le projet de
l'hérédité qui sont contre mais nous on
veut emmener nos citoyens vers ce qu'est
la vie vivre ensemble dans la république
et pour construire des 30 prochaines
années
donc j'ai pas de projets contre oui
bonjour j'ai envoyé un mail à effet vous
avez dit que beaucoup a été fait lors
des trois dernières années parce que
vous estimez que globalement la menace
de l'islam radical a plutôt régressé et
stable ou à continuer à s'aggraver
et quand vous dénoncez les influences
étrangères quels sont selon les pays et
les organisations qui sont les plus
actifs en france
écoutez sur sur l'islam radical
je ne veux pas ici essayé de dire un
bilan parce que ce serait à la fois
manqué d'humilité et franchement prendre
des risques inconsidérés
je pense que notre pays a été frappée
depuis 2012 par par le terrorisme
islamiste
nous le savons nous l'avons vécu dans
notre cher et nous nous sommes
progressivement réarmer si je puis dire
pour affronter ce risque qui nous avait
quittés et on l'a fait sur le plan de la
sécurité avec des lois successives avec
une transformation en termes de
justement de renseignement de forces de
sécurité de justice je peux vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons quand même
collectivement parachever une
organisation qui est je crois pour le
lire efficace pour lutter contre le
terrorisme islamiste est conforme aux
lois de la république et nos valeurs
parce que c'est ça le défi
je rappelle que nous avons quand même
vécu après des attentats de 2015 pendant
plusieurs années en état d'urgence
est ce que nous avons eu à faire aussi
depuis trois ans et parachever une
organisation mais sortir de l'état
d'urgence qui n'est pas une mince
affaire
et donc c'était accepté de dire on va
vivre durablement avec ce risque mais on
doit pouvoir le traiter sans contrevenir
à nos principes républicains
c'est exactement ce qu'on vient de le
faire au delà des organisations donc là
je peux dire qu'on est on a beaucoup
avancé et beaucoup avait été fait avant
que nous arrivions et je salue le
président sarkozy et le président
hollande qui ont eu les premiers
affronter ce risque premier en fin de
mandat président hollande tout au long
de son mandat et qui ou passer
énormément de transformation de réformes
et beaucoup mobilisé est ce que nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans une situation où
il ya un risque zéro
non ça n'est jamais possible parce que
le terrorisme islamiste s'est
transformée là où il était
essentiellement exogènes c'est-à-dire
organisé depuis l'extérieur les attentes
à 2015 sont organisés depuis jaca il est
aujourd'hui se développe sous une forme
qu'on appelle endogène c'est à dire il
est développé par des gens qui sont sur
notre territoire et avec parfois des
organisations qui sont liées à l'islam
radical parfois des individus
les enquêtes le montrent à chaque fois
qu'ils sont très isolés qui peuvent
s'être converti plus ou moins récemment
et qui est aussi ont des phénomènes
je le dit qu' un certain moment relève
de la psychiatrie phénomène de
décompensation la question c'est
maintenant comment réussir à mieux
prévenir cela et ça c'est un travail
extrêmement minutieux qu'il faut
continuer à conduire à la fois pour
mieux suivre les individus on va isoler
par ce devoir de vigilance que
j'évoquais il ya un an et j'ai une
pensée
évidemment pour les victimes de
l'attentât de la préfecture de police
en vous parlant parce qu'il ya quelques
jours on était e ou un an de cet
attentat mais j'avais parlé de justement
de ce devoir de vigilance et d'une
société de vigilance est donc là aussi
chacun un rôle et il y avait eu un
relâchement collectif parce que on
pensait que ce risque ne pardonnait pas
notre quotidien et il va y avoir un
travail très fin pour faire un meilleur
suivi aussi psychiatrique de certains
individus sur ensuite l'islam radical
je pense que nous avons beaucoup
progressé
nous identifions beaucoup mieux le sujet
ces réalités parce qu'il ya un travail
énorme qui a été fait par nos services
de renseignement parce qu'on a réinvesti
massivement dans le renseignement
territoriales durant ces trois dernières
années et on a marié les techniques de
renseignement territoriale avec les
autres services de renseignement parce
qu'on a mis en place tout ce que j'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure de lutte contre la
radicalisation et parce que nos élus ont
fait aussi un travail énorme et qui est
un partenariat qui s'est nouée et un
dialogue que les préfet mène avec leurs
élus pour identifier et là aussi
réengagé tout
donc on a beaucoup progressé est-ce que
la situation est satisfaisante
pas du tout on doit renforcer notre
dispositif et on doit aller beaucoup
plus loin
c'est tout ce que je viens de dire
aujourd'hui sur les financements et les
influences étrangères
nous savons d'où viennent les
financements sont venus très
régulièrement d'arabie saoudite sont
venus du qatar ils sont venus de turquie
ils sont venus plus humain plus
marginalement maroc et de l'algérie
mais quand je dis ça je ne stigmatise
aucun état certains états à des moments
où des politiques de prosélytisme j'ai
eu un dialogue depuis le premier jour
avec mes homologues ces pays pour leur
demander de ne cesser après la
difficulté c'est beaucoup d beaucoup de
financements venant de ces pays viennent
par des structures privées qui ne sont
pas directement étatique c'est pour ça
qu'on doit prendre ce texte qui va nous
permettre de voir quelles sont ces
structures quels sont leurs liens et
pour quel projet quand vous avez une
fondation privée qui fait un financement
pour telle ou telle mosquée ou tel ou
tel projet vous ne savez pas forcément
qui c'est derrière et quelle est la
finalité du projet ce qui est vrai c'est
qu'il y a eu une géopolitique de l'islam
et on la voit partout dans le monde et
que cette géopolitique elle ne
correspond pas aux valeurs qui sont les
nôtres et qui sont celles de notre
diplomatie parce que nous ne croyons pas
à l'islam politique ce n'est pas notre
avis pas compatible avec une stabilité
et une paix dans le monde mais il ya eu
ces dernières années une forme d'
emballement de perte de contrôle et
certains de ces financements sont allés
vers le terrorisme islamiste et son
talent et on l'a vu dans la en syrie
vers les projets terroristes
donc oui il y à il ya eu tous ces
financements nous sommes aujourd'hui
nous les avons je crois pouvoir le dire
beaucoup réduit nous avons fait preuve
d'aucune complaisance mais il nous faut
maintenant pouvoir mieux les contrôler
bonjour monsieur le président vincent de
rose et de la radio rtl vous avez parlez
dans votre discours d'un laisser-faire
nous avons construit notre propre
séparatisme est ce que les maires de
france sont visés par ce nous est ce que
vous avez prévu de les aider localement
de qui sont en première ligne à lutter
contre les dérives religieuses et
al'inverse est ce que vous envisagez des
sanctions pour les élus qui par action
ou inaction ne lutteraient pas
efficacement contre les dérives
si on veut réussir ce projet tout le
monde doit être engagée j'ai pas
commencé à pointer du doigt et à dire il
ya ici ou là ça ne marche pas tout le
monde doit être engagée et moi je veux
engager tout le monde dans une quasi
totalité nos élus il aime la république
je rappelle comme toujours que nous
sommes un pays qui est à cent mille élus
dont une écrasante majorité le fait à
titre bénévole et et où la réalité du
quotidien
c'est quand même qu'ils sont confrontés
qu'ils aux pressions mais la réalité est
là au concret tous ces problèmes donc
très sincèrement nos élus sont engagés
et sont là et ce qu'il ya parfois des
choses qui ne vont pas oui partout
du côté de l'état des parce que la
situation est difficile parce qu'il
n'est plus sous contrôle
donc ce que je vous ai présenté
aujourd'hui c'est donner les moyens aux
élus de se protéger des pressions
lorsqu'elles sont insoutenables ou au
préfet de se substituer aux quelques
élus qui ont des pratiques qui sont
incompatibles avec les lois de la
république
c'est les réponses très claires c'est à
dire possibilité d'avoir un contrôle de
légalité renforcé de demander de
corriger ce qui n'est pas conforme à nos
textes séparation dans les piscines les
menus à la cantine si on prend une
délibération dans le conseil municipal
etc etc et de se substituer à eux comme
on le fait d'ailleurs en logement social
après je pense que ce qu'il faut plutôt
faire c'est aider nos élus à résoudre le
problème parce que nos mères nos élus ce
sont les premiers à subir une
organisation collective on a mis en
place collectivement un système ce
serait trop facile de pointer des
responsabilités
nous avons mis en place un système parce
que nous avons créé progressivement ce
droit au logement une politique qu'on a
appelée de peuplement je suis pas sûr de
le retrouver totalement dans ce terme
qui a des consonances un peu étrange
mais on le sait très bien quand on a
deux les perdu l'hébergement d'urgence
qui arrive dès la procédure
administrative se sont toujours au même
endroit qu'ont mais celles et ceux qui
arrivent sur notre sol et qui demandent
l'asile
d'ailleurs vous noterez se sont rarement
pour le coup les élus qui ont à
accueillir durablement ces personnes
dans l'instruction qui sont les plus
vocaux sur ledit droit d'asile je le dis
par tarentaise mais on entend souvent
des gens qui sont très sains quant à
thouars sur la défense du droit d'asile
de les valeurs de la république
généralement ils n'accueillent pas sur
leur propre sur leur propre commune 1
certaines grandes métropoles
ils n'accueillent pas sur leur commune
ces hébergements d'urgence
ce sont les communes périphériques déjà
en difficulté qui les accueille le mans
d ici les communes en difficulté allez
demander à sarcelles et c'est ça la
réalité est donc ce sont les communes
les plus pauvres qui prennent
l'hébergement d'urgence et après quand
on place dans le logement social
on a les contraintes de l'existant avec
des vrais déséquilibre et on a
aujourd'hui une politique qui amène à
continuer à concentrer les choses bilan
des courses quand vous avez des élus
aidés par les services de l'état qui
réussissent une politique de mobilité
qui arrive à sortir des jeunes puis à
faire de la promotion sociale de la
mobilité à faire réussir des gens dans
leur quartier quand ils ont réussi à
faire sortir une famille elle a fait
remonter il voit deux familles encore
plus en difficulté qui arrive c'est ça
la réalité c'est ça et donc nous avons
parce qu'il ya plus de pression
migratoire ces dernières années et parce
qu'on a gardé des structures qui ne sont
plus adaptés une politique
d'organisation de notre logement d'un
pays qui n'est plus adaptée à cette
réalité nous nous sommes en train de
construire la possibilité de réussir
cette intégration est donc ce que je
veux c'est qu'on change ses règles et
qu'on est politique beaucoup plus juste
et répartis sur le territoire des
l'hébergement d'urgence des
l'hébergement d'urgence et qu'on ait des
seuils d'alert qui fait que l'on laisse
d'abord un territoire sans sortir une
commune s'en sortir et régler ces
problèmes avant de lui rajouter d'autres
et on demande à d'autres de contribuer
monsieur le président bonjour marie
chanterait pour ses instincts lci vous